when you look at how how Trump gets
treated I mean again I think Trump is as
OD as a character as I can think of
really I mean some ways more odious than
people who are objectively worse right I
mean some ways I you know I have more
respect for someone like Osama bin Laden
than I do for Trump for a variety of
reasons but so it might my animus toward
Trump is it can you know verges on the
paradoxical in what sense is it because
of the lack of you don't you don't find
Trump genuine in a way that you find or
found Osama bin Laden genuine or I'm
interested in that yeah there's
something there I mean it's it's I think
in my model of Osama bin Laden's mind is
that he actually could have been a
psychologically healthy deeply ethical
person and truly compassionate person
ruled by some terrible ideas and this is
what worries me most about jihadism I
mean I see jihadism as the kind of
perfect mind virus where you can
actually be a good person but if you're
captivated by these idea ideas you can
behave in a way that you know not even
the worst Psychopaths get up to most of
the time right and so there's you know
that that's one form of violence and
that's one you know typology of it and
but it but in Trump I see a genuinely
disordered personality right he seems
like he has no moral core right I mean
if I believed in Souls and you told me
that you know his his had been removed
you know that would account for for the
problem I mean I just see I see somebody
who is so naked ly selfish and
narcissistic and unmoored to any value
system that I recognize that he actually
he's there's something scarcely human
about him I mean he's he's so in that
sense he's actually worse than people
who have who have created much more harm
intentionally someone like Osama bin
Laden I recognize in you know sama bin
Laden I recognize a fully human person
running some very bad software your
Trump Trump does not seem that way to me
he has no ideology that I can detect
apart from his own self concern and you
know he's just like he's he's he strikes
me as a kind of moral lunatic right and
I wouldn't say that of most jihadists
you know frankly